واحده من العناصر
اللي اسهمت بشكل مباشر في تعقيد
سرديه الهويه ان شئت تجارب الاستعمار
المتعدده والمتنوعه التي خضعت لها هذه
الجغرافيا بحدودها اللي هي اصلا رسمها
الاستعمار من الاستعمار يعود الى ما قبل
الميلاد طبعا عرفت الممالك النوبيه
القديمه خدعت لاستعمار الفراعنه يعني
الاسر المعروفه في التاريخ
بالاضافه الى
الجغرافيا السودان وحتى هذه اللحظه هي
كانت
ندبه حقيقيه ليش لانه هو في الوسط ومفتوح
على عدد هائل من يعني
الجيوبوليتكس الثانيه المجاوره يعني عرفت
هذه حدوده منذ الازل لا طبعا لا طبعا يعني
مر الاطوار عديده جدا يعني ما يعرف اليوم
بممالك النيل
هي كانت يعني حدودها من جنوب مصر
وحتى حدود جنوب السودان اليوم او ممكن بعد
فرازخ ليس اكثر يعني
في كل مره طبعا الجغرافيا السياسيه تتغير
تعرف الغزوات والتاريخ اللي هو معروف
ومكتوب ومقروء والتواصل معه بيحصل من فتره
الشاهد في هذا الامر يعني انه التجارب
الخضع عليها السودان
كانت متنوعه ومتعدده اسهمت يا استاذ مشاري
بشكل مباشر في انقطاعات مد قومي
وعلى فكره انا لم اقل هذا الكلام قاله
المفكر الاقتصادي الراحل سميره مين قال
انه السودان والجزائر في المحيط العربي
والافريقي بالتحديد يعني اسوا ما خلفه
الاستعمار ان شئت انه عمل الاستعمار بشكل
مباشر وبشكل غير مباشر حتى كمان على قطع
المد القومي والوطني
وهذه مره مهمه يعني لا تتصور انه
مالات هذا الامر نعاني منها حتى هذه
اللحظه
يعني حتى مساله الهويه نفسها ملتبسه جدا
في كثير من جوانبه لسبب بسيط لانه ما زالت
جينات التجربه بتاعت الاستعمار متجليه في
الخطاب يعني وطبعا اوله خطاب السياسي
وكل
الجوانب الابعاد الثانيه والاثر الاكبر
ويفترض انه نحن ننتقل لموضوع مهم له علاقه
بهذه النقطه انه كان له اثر مباشر في
البنيه النفسيه للانسان في هذه الجغرافيا
يعني
خليط يعني عدد هائل من القبائل